good evening a 39 year old man driving a
pickup was killed in a crash last night
and what triggered it
has been causing problems in one valley
neighborhood for quite some time
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis now this all
happened in the northwest valley right
near tanea and lake mead
not only did one man die three others
were injured
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough live on teneo with more on the
neighbors there and
they say this was just a devastating but
not really surprising accident
yeah so that's correct so neighbors say
that this is just another crash
to happen in their neighborhood as cars
come speeding by here
every single day making it hard for them
to feel safe and secure
in their own home my house is right
there we
constantly hearing the motors going
monday night's accident is causing
concern in this northwest valley
neighborhood
those who live in the houses that line
the four-lane road say this is the first
fatality they've seen
but not the first car crash it makes it
difficult for people like jose nunez to
trust letting his kids out to play
my kids play in this area over here
sometimes
you know they even go through here
pretty fast though so yeah
it is work nunez says he and his
neighbors have tried to put up cones to
make drivers slow down on his street
but feels there's nothing he can do
about the cars on the major four-lane
road
he says he feels people go a good 20 to
25 over the speed limit of 35 miles per
hour
a lot of accidents and on this
intersection
people trying to cross and you know
there's no lights or anything to
for people to stop or slow down
so this always crashes in the right on
that corner
in the crash monday night the pickup
truck did not hit the home behind the
brick wall
but the homeowners did say they heard a
loud bang as their home shook
police say the front of the truck
collided with the rear of a smaller
vehicle
causing the pickup truck to redirect and
run into the brick wall
all right so take a look as this is the
brick wall that we're talking about that
the truck ran
into yesterday you can really see there
are already remnants of
car the car parts right here and you can
see it really did some major damage to
this brick wall
that has a home right behind it now
unfortunately neighbors say it's only a
matter of time
for another crash like this to happen
again hopefully
not this severe reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now